probably the most common question that
I'm asked as a professor at Hillsdale is
what happened to my country you know
when they poll Americans they find that
a vast majority don't think the world is
going to be a better place for their own
children
in this course we're going to look at
who the mid-century liberals were and
the changes that they introduced into
American society we're also going to
look at the radicals the
counter-culturalists of the 1960s and
the changes that remain with us today
we're going to look at the group called
The neoliberals and the formation of an
oligarchy in the American regime in the
1980s and the 1990s and finally we'll
see how those radicals in the 60s made
peace with those neoliberal oligarchs in
the great awokening and Barack Obama's
second term and the threat that it poses
to Republican Liberties for us today
these movements are promising to strip
away all of the rights and the freedoms
that give life happiness and meaning and
purpose I don't think people understand
the source of most current ideologies
and what this course is going to show us
is where they originated and how they
took control of our society you'll see
the changes that have taken place in
America the ideas that are responsible
for those changes and how we as
Americans can challenge those ideas and
reclaim our American Heritage this is
our course on the American left
let's begin
[Music]